one of the really cool things about
estuaries is that salt water is heavier
than fresh water when the river meets
the sea fresh water actually floats on
top for a surprisingly long time between
the two layers is a transition line
called the hocine what this means is
that if you're a saltwater dolphin
exploring the mouth of a river near the
surface of the water you get to hunt
freshwater fish but then if you need a
little bit of salt all you have to do is
dive down this really helps in The
evolutionary transition from salt water
to fresh water here's a little bit of
footage that hook at a tide pool in
Oregon on the top here we see fresh
water coming in from a river a little
stream and it's dumping into a tide pool
when I put my hand in you can see about
5 in down there is the saltwater
freshwater line the salt content of the
water is so different that it refracts
light differently and you can see as I
move my hand through that line through
the hline you can see the halocline just
with the naked eye it's really cool